hi and welcome to building a virtual
post-production suite my name is Adrian
Graham and I'm a Solutions Architect for
media and entertainment at Google cloud
today I want to talk about content
creation workflows and how Google clouds
products can support these types of
workloads for a creative workforce that
spans the world we're going to look at
how artists such as designers animators
or editors can collaborate across vast
distances using the solution that takes
advantage of Google's global private
fiber network to reduce latency and
improve the overall user experience
content creation is a global market and
access to talent is essential for
finding the right artist for the job
even if they live on the other side of
the globe companies who want to take
advantage of regional production tax
credits need to hire talent in these
locations but building a new physical
facility to house these artists can be
cost and time prohibitive it doesn't
make sense to build a new facility in a
new location for every new production
but on Google Cloud it's possible today
I'm going to show you a virtual
post-production suite that allows
artists to work with their favorite
tools but with the added flexibility and
power of Google Cloud consider the main
components of a virtual post-production
suite people such as artists producers
and engineers virtual workstations to
create and manage content shared storage
so users can collaborate compute
clusters for rendering or transcoding
media asset management systems and
databases to keep track of assets and
archive and disaster recovery to ensure
durability and to properly store data
with a virtual post-production suite all
members of a content creation team can
access the same assets and resources
regardless of physical location cloud
native features such as data encryption
identity access management and
multi-factor authentication ensure high
value content is secure and available
only to those granted access Google
Cloud is authorized by major Hollywood
studios to host Tier one content we work
with international security evaluators
and other third-party auditors to ensure
compliance with security best practices
local laws and regulations to build a
virtual post-production suite on Google
cloud we need three things a client so
artists can connect from their local
workstation laptop or dedicated hardware
device
a broker that authenticates users with
an identity service such as G suite or
Active Directory once authenticated the
user traffic is then routed to their
assigned resource the artist is then
connected to their workstation here
artists can access common resources such
as shared file systems asset management
databases our kyv workflows and other
cloud-based resources to automate tasks
such as transcoding or rendering to
connect to our workstations we're going
to use PC over IP technology a remote
display protocol from Terra deechi PC
over IP technology empowers artists
editors and engineers to display
lossless high resolution high frame rate
images and video across multiple
monitors on a variety of endpoint
devices from laptops to highly secure
stateless PC over IP 0 clients using
Terra DG cloud access software which is
built on this PC over IP technology I
can connect to a workstation running in
the Los Angeles region once
authenticated I'm logged in to my
virtual workstation running Windows 2019
server with Windows desktop experience
this is an NVIDIA Quadro virtual
workstation using an Nvidia p4 GPU as
well as Terra DG cloud access software
on my workstation I can open an existing
project in Adobe Premiere Pro according
to GC Pinkham my latency to this
workstation in the LA region is only
around 20 milliseconds so the experience
feels like a local workstation audio is
synchronized properly and I can scrub
the timeline without lag or delay I'm
going to upload some footage from my
local workstation to the cloud volume to
do this I'm using IBM aspera on cloud
once uploaded I can move this footage
into my cloud volume I could also use
other industry standard file transfer
tools such as Cygnet or even drive file
stream for ingesting footage I'm going
to add this footage to my edit and drop
it into the timeline then I'm going to
pass the modified project over to
another editor let's bring in my
colleague Marku a Solutions Architect
who is based in Tokyo he's going to make
some additional changes to this edit
then send it back to me for rendering
hey thanks Adrian ok on my cloud
workstation I can see it the edits that
you made I can see the exact same
project data because we are using an
edible Obul file cast and when I open
the set Premiere Pro project any assets
of files that changed will be read
across
cause network and cast locally to the
Tokyo region I'm going to add my own
footage from the game using the same
technique that Adrienne did
and once this footage is available I
will add it to the Edit I save my
changes to the team project and now
Adrienne users get a notification thanks
mark ooh I see those changes almost
immediately on my workstation and the
footage you uploaded is coming across
now
all right thanks Adrienne see you later
I could render this edit on my virtual
workstation on a separate server running
Adobe Media encoder or using any one of
our partner transcoding solutions on
Google Cloud for this project I'm
rendering the video on another instance
when the render is done I can view the
result on my virtual workstation and
play back the videos I generated at full
resolution this is a relatively simple
example of a virtual post-production
suite we didn't cover asset ingestion or
archive and disaster recovery we also
didn't explore how intelligent content
discovery can help content creators
understand organize and monetize their
assets on Google cloud this demo showed
you connecting to and performing editing
tasks on a cloud workstation uploading
footage from a local workstation for use
in my edit collaboration with others
sharing my project anywhere in the world
and how data can be securely
synchronized across Google cloud regions
there's a lot of new and exciting
projects were working on to take media
and entertainment workloads to the next
level check the documentation to learn
more and thanks for watching
you
[Music]